hello firstly do you like do you like
when your fairy lights cuz cuz I like my
new fairy lights in fact I actually like
them so much that I put them at number
10 on my top 10 list of in fact I
actually like them so much that I've put
them at number 10 on my top 10 list of
things that make me happy
which is what I'm gonna talk about today
you coming in at number 9 on my list yes
excuse me listen I'm sure that's a very
important banging you've got going on in
there I'm trying on the video
requirements so if you can just like not
do that just for a while I would really
appreciate it please thank you thank you
very much in at number 9 on my list
listen mate I don't want to get angry
but if you oh hey good charlie
how's it going man
hello firstly do you like to let my evil
fairy lights I lie my oval fairy lights
so as you might already guessed from the
parallel universe office and the eye
patch in the yes Pogo t-shirt I and evil
charlie so welcome to my lair I should
probably apologize for knocking out you
know the nice charlie and taking him
captive but I'm not going to apologize
because you know evil and that if act
really for me
at least this is something to be
celebrated because I have been trying
for months to pluck up the courage to
lure good Charlie into my office take
him out and now there he is
lying unconscious in my lair the only
thing left now is I've just got to try
and decide what evil thing to do to it
my evil handbook of evil says that the
evilest thing that I could possibly do
to a hostage right now is murder
hit him which I'm not quite at that
level of evil just yet based on my
personal level of evil probably the best
thing that I can do at this point is um
throw water in his face that that's
horrible that's I like that one one of
the experiences that I've had personally
in which someone has thrown water in my
face
I've been they've been pretty unpleasant
so I think I'm gonna go with that one I
thought I'd knocked you out well to be
fair you did knock me out you just
didn't do it very well how long have you
been awake
pretty much the whole time to be honest
definitely long enough to hear about
your extremely evil plan which I am
terrified about by the way yeah so I
guess that must have made you feel
really evil right a little bit listen
this is just my opinion but I heard
everything you were talking about over
there and you kept on calling me like
good charlie or the nice charlie but I
don't let those words define me I'm just
Charlie so maybe you're not evil charlie
maybe you're just Charlie too but you
know with an eyepatch do you really
think that yeah you seem like a nice
enough guy even if your mole is on the
wrong side of your face hey your mole is
on the wrong side of your face so you
forgive me
throwing water menu of course so long as
you untie me and get me a towel in
another night on my list you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
charlieissocoollike which makes you like
cool
nobody's just kids or just evil
everyone's a bit of both
that's the moral the video it's good yes
I guess that must have made you feel
really evil right yeah ready